felt like I was going to the principal  office man and you I had to walk up  these stairs to get to George Payton  office and you know I get up there I go  in the room and George had like this  little button to like close the door and  then he just got straight into it he's  like well let's take his glasses off put  him down I want to let you know that we  are trading you to Los Angeles Rams and  I said whoa like  because in Frio you see you get a chance  to say goodbye you know when you get  traded it's just like boom you get 45  minutes pack up your stuff that you want  to take now and then we're going to ship  everything else to you you don't get no  chance to say no goodbye crazy it ain't  that ain't true that ain't true when I  got cut like it was the conversation we  had then walk downstairs try to say  goodbye to everybody real quick and once  you walk out of that building you can't  come back it's over